Let's do a little bit of an
exercise with spread so we can
get the hang of it. Now I'm
going to use the simplest form
of it, which is spreading a
string. What I want you to do is
build this where, look how fun
this is. When you hover over one
of these letters, they animate
themselves on in. I've given
you some CSS, but you can feel
free to grab that from the
answer if you don't like writing
CSS. Otherwise, I thought it
would be fun to try to get that
yourself. Then you are just
given this, an H2 tag with a
class of jump and it has spreads.
You know that you can't hover on
an individual letter inside of
an H2, but you can take a look
at what I've done here. If I
take a look at my elements panel,
look at this, H2 with the class
of jump. Inside of that, each
one is wrapped in a span. I want
you to use map, a spread, and
query selector all to select the
element. Give that maybe 5
or 10 minutes to try to do it
yourself, and then come on back
to this video and I'm going to
explain how we would use spreads
to solve this. Welcome back.
What I would like to do here is,
first of all I would like to
grab this H2 here. I would say
const heading = document query
sector. I have the actual
heading element, and I need to
take the text out of the spread,
wrap every single item in a span,
and then put it back into, so
I'm going to create a function.
I like to call this SparanWrap,
which is wrapping every single
one in spans. I'm going to say
function, SparanWrap. That is a
function which takes in a word
and it's going to return a bunch
of HTML where it is. How
does that work? Let's work
through this together. We'll
console log that word and see
where we are at, and go ahead
and run this. I'm going to say
SparanWrap is heading.text
content. That will give me the
actual word spreads inside of it.
We've got the word spreads here,
but we don't want that. We want
every single word to be an
individual item. What we can do
is we will spread that word.
We're going to return...word. If
we stick this in a const spans =
and console log that spans up
here, we should be able to see,
good. Now the spreads is now in
its own array. Why? Because
we took every single item out of
the word and spread it. That's
not good enough, because we need
to return not just an array, but
we need to have every single
letter wrapped. That is a
good use case for .map, where
we're going to take in a letter.
In return, we'll return a
template string where is just a
span, and inside of that we have
the letter. We loop over every
single letter and return that
letter, but wrapped in a span.
Span, span, OK good, but still
not perfect because we've got
all these commas here. We don't
want an array. We want a string,
so we just call join on the end
there. There we go, that's our
HTML. We should now be able
to say heading.enter HTML = take
this SparanWrap here, get rid of
this unnecessary variable, and
pass in the text content.
Refresh, you don't see anything,
but go ahead and inspect them.
Look what's happening on page
load. You can't even see it, it
goes so fast. In page load,
we're taking the word out,
wrapping in spans, and
immediately injecting it right
back into the page there. That
looks good. Now let's do the
CSS part where, when you hover
over a span, we needed it to
animate up. We'll say jump span
hover. I'm just going to say
color black, make sure it
actually works here. Good,
now we know that that's working.
We can say transform,
translate, Y -20PX. See where
we're at. Doesn't work. Why
not? Because spans are inline,
and you cannot translate Y on
the inline element. We'll say
display inline block. That seems
to be working, but we want that
nice little animation, so I'm
going to say transition,
transform. I'm going to
transition the transform
property over 03 seconds or
something like that. Looking
good. Maybe a little bit faster
for nicer animation, looks good.
Now we can go ahead and play
with this translate Y. We'll say
rotate 10 degrees and scale to...
looks good. Pretty happy with
that. That's just a quick
example of when you would use a
spread. Rather than splitting
and mapping over it, we can just
spread the word immediately. It
makes for a little bit of a
nicer code base. I'll see
you in the next video, where we
look at some more examples of
when we would use this in our
code.